toxic masculinity seems to have been
completely misunderstood by online
reactionaries
back during 2016 youtube the dark ages
if you listen to these people back then
you would think that toxic masculinity
means that masculinity itself
is toxic and this narrative fit very
conveniently into this whole
gamergate era capital g gamers and
skeptics fighting against the evil
feminists who are trying to take away
our masculinity because they think all
men are sexist and so they have this
term called toxic masculinity which
means that all men are evil sexists and
should get rid of masculinity you get
the idea
but surprise surprise this is not true
toxic masculinity
does not mean that masculinity is toxic
and it's actually a pro-male
term discussions about toxic masculinity
are very helpful to men
now how does this work for example lots
of boys are told that they should keep
their feelings down if they have
suffered an emotional hurt they should
not be sharing it with anyone
and they certainly shouldn't cry but why
in ancient greece public displays of
emotions were considered a manly thing
shedding tears publicly was considered
to be authentic and courageous
or you know alpha to use modern
terminology
teaching young boys to just bottle up
their feelings and cut themselves off
from any sort of emotional support
network
is a very harmful practice and an
example of toxic masculinity
another example is the normalization of
violence among young boys
do we remember that gillette ad the one
that caused a collective mental
breakdown among reactionaries a few
years ago
in it there's this very creative visual
of a bunch of dads standing with their
grills in a row
going boys will be boys as two kids
scuffle with each other on the lawn this
scene is meant to reflect on the fact
that we normalize violence among boys
and of course a friendly scuffle between
two kids is not the issue
it's all this additional baggage of yeah
well you know boys and men sometimes
they just need to go at each other you
know
to live out their masculine side to
unleash the beast within
yeah and then bullying happens so is
bullying a good thing hey the bully just
unleashed the beast within he's just
living out his masculine essence
you know it's not his fault that the kid
he's bullying is too much of a [ __ ] to
retaliate
stuff like this is also toxic
masculinity the third example would be
a fatiguation of self-reliance not only
are boys taught to just bottle up their
feelings they're also told that asking
for help is a feminine thing
like if a man is driving somewhere and
gets lost and so
asks for help that is emasculating
but why though you know some people
would make an argument like
back in the ancient days men were the
rugged hunters roaming the plains and so
not asking for directions on the way to
mcdonald's is an expression of this
ancient
male virtue but the thing is i can do
the reverse and say
hey in the ancient era hunting was a
very dangerous business
and men did it in groups therefore it is
natural for men to ask for help
when they get lost on the way to
mcdonald's they immediately pull over
and ask the first person for help which
is an expression of this ancient
masculine virtue so yeah the
fetishization of self-reliance is also
toxic masculinity
and when you combine these three things
bottling up your emotions
normalizing physical violence and
fetishizing self-reliance
you get a high male suicide rate
battered husbands who don't ask for help
domestic abuse shelters that are
available only for women
boys emotionally scarred by bullying or
male domestic abuse victims who get
ridiculed and laughed at when they try
to ask for
all of this results from toxic
masculinity it doesn't mean that
masculinity is toxic
it means that we have some very harmful
and well
toxic ideas about what masculinity
should be
and that we should work against those
things feminists who bring up the issue
of toxic masculinity
try to help men and i find the irony
astounding that they get harangued by
these capital g
gamers and capital s skeptics because
first off
they agree on the problem so they should
be natural allies
and second how fragile do you have to be
how
unsure you have to be in your
masculinity for a razor company's
youtube ad to cause this big of a freak
out
masculinity is not a bad thing the fact
that we have all these harmful and toxic
ideas about what masculinity should be
is a bad thing it results in bad
outcomes
and in general decreases the well-being
of men and so
i'm against it i want people to be happy
i want
men to be happy and so i don't
purposefully misunderstand feminist
terms
meant to help men so this is the idea
behind toxic masculinity
i hope you've enjoyed the content and in
the meantime please don't forget to like
and subscribe
i also have a patreon so if you think
this kind of content is worth your time
please consider supporting me in doing
just that